i wanted to make a certain point that
has dawned on me um over the course of
months
there's obviously a relationship between
these mandates and
[Music]
tragedies of the past and anybody who
raises that connection is subject to
being demonized as somebody who is
uh taking you know the deaths of jews
and the holocaust lightly or something
like that and
frankly i'm having none of it right
we are in a place
where the lessons of the past are
directly relevant because we are
remaking mistakes that we've seen before
are we remaking them identically no are
we remaking them for the same reasons
probably not but are those lessons
relevant and if so are we liberated to
talk about them we damn well better be
and the point i wanted to make
is
we are watching the rollback of
the nuremberg code and the gains made at
nuremberg and i believe we're seeing it
on two separate fronts that are easily
conflated because it went down in such a
way that they were both in play
one of them has to do with the idea that
a human being is morally obligated to
reject
immoral orders
this is a very important principle the
nazis were put on trial at nuremberg all
used the defense that they had been
following orders
and the point was the world correctly
decided
that no such defense was viable that if
the order was immoral you had an
obligation to reject it even though
that's obviously a very
uh dire choice right and you know
let's give the defense it's due
does that mean you know in states that
have the death penalty that if somebody
tells you you know that you are
obligated to put somebody to death that
you are obligated to reject it it's not
clear what it means because it's not
clear that it's an immoral order now i
happen to personally oppose the death
penalty i believe there are cases in
which it is morally justified but that
we actually don't have a system good
enough to deploy it and therefore we
don't need it it isn't useful and we
should forbid it we will be more
civilized if we forgo it but it doesn't
mean there aren't people who've earned
it right right you like i prefer to make
the other error
i think we have to make the other error
it's the it's the civilized error to
make but in any case the point is there
are lawful orders potentially or at
least arguably that do result in a
person you know
going to war there are wars that are
justified and you will kill other people
during them so is it an immoral order
just because somebody dies no not
inherently
but the nazis claim to have been
following orders
was
ruled
a non-defense right right
now we are in the process of um
purging our police forces our military
our universities our hospitals of
exactly the people who were most likely
to raise objections people who
recognized that there was something
wrong with these mandate policies and
refused to either apply them to others
or to accept them for themselves the
number of people we've heard from
who have nurses in the family or doctors
but we've heard from more nurses and
nurses in the family who are no longer
allowed to work
in an era when we are also being told uh
that we that
not so much now but two months ago you
know the hospitals are overfill or
overflowing right we're in crisis mode
and yet we're firing people for making a
choice of conscience right and what i
would say is whether it's intentional or
not
the consequence that this policy of
firing people from police forces the
military hospitals universities for
resisting is to create
police forces military
universities hospitals in which people
are much less likely to object to
immoral orders and that is hugely
dangerous you leave behind a compliant
population right but the other way in
which we were rolling back nuremberg is
that nuremberg focused on the medical
experiments that were inflicted on
victims and concentration camps
now
what was ruled at nuremberg was that
human beings have a right to informed
consent that is to say that they have to
be able to say no to participating in
experiment and they have to have the
basis on which to make the judgment
themselves which means they need to be
fully informed
now
we have pointed out before
that these vaccines mrna vaccines for
example
are
one of the probably the largest medical
experiment in human history but for one
thing but for the fact that we are
apparently not systematically collecting
data on what happened to people who got
them and comparing it to people who
didn't in order to figure out how
dangerous or not they are so it is an
experiment in one sense in the sense
that we don't know but it is not an
experiment in the sense that we are not
taking even that responsibility
seriously
yeah it's an experiment in the
lay person in the in the lay sense of
experiment but it's not a scientific
experiment right and if there's one
thing we can be certain of you and i
having traversed this ground many times
it's that it is almost impossible to
find good information on what the risks
are
and how common the harms are and when
you do look at what evidence we do have
you're told it's not reliable without
being told what is reliable and so the
point is the informed consent
requirement that was established so
thoroughly i mean we literally hung
doctors
right we hung doctors as a result of
those trials right
that informed consent is now out the
window we are in an experimental phase
there are things that are true
based on whether or not the vial that
you happen to be injected from is part
of the emergency youth use authorized
batch or whether it is the
fda approved version and apparently the
authorized batch is the only thing you
can get in the u.s this is a baroque
landscape that no person could possibly
understand where their interests
actually are and what risks they're
being put to so informed consent is out
the window and those who would object on
the basis that they are being asked to
in to apply an experimental remedy to
people who have not been informed
properly those people are subject to
losing their jobs and so
i don't know if
the
rolling back of the gains of nuremberg
is intentional but i do know that it's
extremely dangerous and what i would say
is that we are effectively setting the
stage for
a tragedy of history
and
we are obligated
to recognize that and to resist with
everything we've got
[Music]